hey guys we're YouTube sensations Ryan
riding charity we are so famous we are
so awesome that we're gonna watch a
trailer for a youtuber who significantly
smaller than both of us a man named
Shane Dawson
nice who'd never heard of this guy don't
quite get it like what the big deal is
about him I mean who the [ __ ] is shane
dawson he ain't us he's never been on
the channel is that the main character
on Dawson's Creek no no no no no no he's
somebody who's a youtuber apparently has
a movie now that's exciting
yes may I give a [ __ ] on my channel Ted
jealous yeah [ __ ] you you're jealous I'm
sorry I didn't mean it I mean I yeah be
nice at one movie would be nice Evan we
hope this is a comedy Shane Dawson
premiers his first movie with a heavy
yes sci-fi drama edge of tomorrow party
edge of tomorrow meets the road edge of
the dust it to the Dawson
[Music]
hurry okay spider-man
the hell's wrong with these people are
you fine sorry what
who doesn't love Thanksgiving great me
high school [ __ ] sucked
ah [ __ ] two easier just pretend laughing
oh that's adorable you're still obsessed
with her it's only gonna sit on my face
literally wow that's really not how that
goes down at all but here's the thing
about high school it ends and you get to
go to college
only problem is and the hot is roll
around you still have to go home
[Music]
sorry but you came out of nowhere
[Music]
miss high schools high schools over that
big ceremony things we all did that was
graduation where we all move on we all
do different things you don't stay here
and be like oh I was prompting and cools
my music school forever you want no
secret it's the first time on a Friday
I've actually done anything
[ __ ] it Liz okay what is this some kind
of bucket list thought we should show
the steps the green screen this is on
the YouTube I like you as a friend
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
feel something like a connection
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
better late than never I did an hour and
a half of weird skits I feel like I
would understand this a lot more if I
never watch the Shane does it was not
not personalized personal for me he
[ __ ] one of my girl I really loved
ones is a Shane Dawson [ __ ] girl I loved
what yeah never since then I've been out
for Shane Dawson this is what murder
you're joking oh do you think I would
have told you about that by now
yeah you probably never intention that's
you right away especially yeah hmm with
this video with YouTube its various you
know affiliates a becoming your life I
figured who would yeah okay look it's
great that he has a great YouTube career
and that he's lost she's able to do a
movie now I don't have anything against
him movie doesn't look that good yeah
there's not look good
as it looks like it has a lot of cheap
jokes it feels like funny even as [ __ ]
it feels like random skits mixed with
trying to be a heartfelt high school
drama comedy I've like I don't know
exactly what the hell is so I'm supposed
to be yeah when he's doing at any Murphy
thing where he's gonna be playing like
fairies yeah a role like this yes in the
weight shot feels like a YouTube movie
you know yeah yeah nothing's anything
wrong with YouTube we love you guys we
do we do yeah no but it does again I
maybe I'm just don't know maybe this is
like really for for people who know his
channel really well yeah I'm not sure is
no probably still gonna make a [ __ ] on a
monkey cuz he just tells his subscribers
to go watch it if I don't know because
because the Internet has been as long
proven to be a sort of unreliable gauge
for who will actually show up to a movie
or not case in point
like Scott Pilgrim people go apeshit
over those books and people went apeshit
when they were gonna make the movie and
it didn't make a whole lot of money hmm
case closed you proved your point this
is one example driven and it just feels
a little weird to say that about his
movie because I'm like he's
much more massively successful you don't
want to think I'm saying that just
because I don't wanted to think like
yeah I'm just trying to take down Shane
Dawson or some no no I mean clearly Z's
making it work and I can't imagine that
it costs so much that it won't be a
success just because you know it doesn't
take a lot of money to make something
like this it doesn't look like they made
it with a lot of money you know it's
like he came from YouTube and I worry if
this is the kind of stuff that might
play better in YouTube format that's
what I mean it looks like a bunch of
YouTube videos combined yeah you know
it's sort of sort of flexed out into a
semi I can't tell if it's gonna be like
a cohesive whole movie or if it's gonna
be like vignettes or something trailer
really showed a lot of his softer side
in everything when I was like that's a
different Shane Dawson I'm over used to
but oh okay I just want the funny ha-ha
is it mostly funny I was opposed to
Shane Dawson it has to be I mean it's an
indie comedy I don't realize you did
sketches I thought I thought he was like
a vlogger I think it was both I feel
like we should we should know a little
bit more about Jane dot right now I feel
like I feel like this this part of the
YouTube trajectory is like once your
channel it's big enough and whatever
show you made takes off then you started
yeah cuz like everybody's got that and
whatever show they do doesn't people
will kind of [ __ ] it looks like a
straight to DVD movie yeah little bit it
looks like one of those room is like bad
for a straight-a DVD coming but it's for
a movie release the Eaters and stuff
teachers well yeah you know it's it's
like mystery team is for the fans of
Derrick home and it just does you know
any of the Fred movies are for the fans
of Fred's so I imagine that fans will
probably really enjoyed oh absolutely
absolutely and for for me who's just
never I don't know much of his stuff I
don't know
and like hard candies like a comedy for
like people who bag on pedophilia
exactly you got a point so down yeah I'm
sure Ellen Page was a great dude it was
hilarious I it was so funny when he was
getting castrated totes
dude castration is where the real comedy
gold is that oh that's like that's all
I've does the only I just
a road economy script another the only
kind of joke I decide you I will
personally fund that entire movie then
ah please I've been looking for a backer
for a long time I know people keep
passing on it I don't understand why so
it's like money in the [ __ ] bucket
every time somebody passes up my script
I'm like I guess I just have to add more
castration jokes that's clearly what
this is missing so you know I'm up to
610 now that's a pretty good number I
try Devin
i-i've for maybe around 650 if you can
get up to 650
we got Oscar gold already immersing them
in the long time since a comedy won best
picture you know I'm saying I think I
have another 40 castration jokes anyway
guys if you're new to the channel o do
some stuff you should click that sub e
sub sub button you should and Jerry has
a playlist called reasons to Jerry you
can jer-bear on his little charity R
underwear sexual affair devil's lair
hairy like a bear he wants to sing like
cher what's gonna happen is gonna shave
with some me there he's gonna go down to
the devil's lair I want to say some
things and you best be aware that when I
go around you're gonna welcome to the
fair say it's unfair when I go around
with the chair bare could you be doing
reviews in his car and we'd be going so
far he's gonna be a star talk about
movie stars and he's gonna go around
this world like ja ja Binks and now Ryan
is going off these links he wants to do
something in his lyrics being a sink he
can't think of anything else to come
next as he wasn't expecting to rap oh
crap I'm on Santa's lap no Christmas
time Christmas time Ryback a few months
away by back to nothing
Sean Drake hi Ryan
I love your videos and channel then a
sub since your desolation of smaug
reaction so can i have a shout out
please Hospital well it's been a while
since you did a really wait reaction
after the movie yeah I did we react to
the trailer for this movie
yeah yeah I remember that the theater's
vision
I appreciate you subscribing Sean Drake
Drake is a great rapper you know he
talks about being depressed and loving
girls and Sean is like Sean Bean
famously portrayed as a character
I mean famously performed in the Game of
Thrones television series Tom means
always a bad guy and or dies or he does
except in that one movie he's really
learned how to die well Dan he's got the
best entry in Hollywood Kevin Castro
give me a shout out like your ripped
shirt style and nice tits did Kevin
Castro thanks for noticing my tits my
friend oh [ __ ] I do have nice tits I've
seen I have a girlfriend she has boobs
from my boobs way nicer than her boobs
she'll vouch for that
oh my hairy chest oh yeah that adds it's
like a garnish most the time she'll just
squeeze my boobs and I'll just be like
oh yeah squeeze my tits I specifically
say that squeeze my tips squeeze my
titties yes like a my titties that's
right Kevin Castro revealing the truth
for you my friend Emmanuel Perez where's
my boo in shout out Brut my [ __ ] show
notice what [ __ ] shut up brew brew
he's a Scottish Spaniard or like a
cockney yeah over like a cockney yeah
ma'am um your shout outs right here man
you want you want to pick a fight
hiya Manuel pérez you want to fight is
that him huh yo now you son of a [ __ ]
oh yeah you want to fight with me you
dumb son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] your mother
take a little farm boy Frost Ryan loved
the vids man can you give me a shout-out
I've asked like 10 times I'm sorry to
feel bad for myself so can I just get
one I had no idea what you're talking
about
boy frost I would remember namely boy
frost
this reminds me of Thor ah yes a wife
Rosa Frosty's the but Ross that's the
correct word Frosty's
boy frost reminds you of when you like
stick your penis into the snow and it
shrivels up and becomes small like a
little boy we frosted it does a very
logical explanation to why you would
think that it boy frost is now some
someone add it to urban dictionary right
now now you dude though you did they
will do it that's how the internet work
and say who invented it by right right
boy I came up with a base up another
subscribers name a sex a sex maneuver
yeah is something BAE Roger
the BAE Roger is basically with you Oh
dip your balls in a woman's mouth
urinate over her so it makes a fountain
tapped in like a thing I mean the
problem is that of all the weird sex
moves that are out there that one is
actually possible yes you gotta be in a
right direction it makes them come in
yeah like logistically speaking this is
doable and that's kind of upset so we it
would be difficult to make it work right
but I bet you took some guys YouTube
Nathan made up a fake sex move but that
is within the realm of the bounds of
reality so we got boy frost via Rogers I
just need one more subscribe just one
more name people true love oh you love
are we hinting at the next possible
shout-out oh [ __ ] tune in next week's
video good more tomorrow ever now I
don't know take care my side well the
real readings right I'll have to go soon
who will get shattered out next okay I'm
kind of camera